[Applauso]
[Musica]
Ciao a tutti sono Antonello Taurino e
sono un docente della scuola pubblica
italiana
mi aspettavo un silenzio di
commiserazione
no essendo un docente proprio per questa
mia professione Non posso fare a meno di
notare sui social su internet che
insomma sul tema scuola istruzione a
volte girano delle frasi dei meme e io
mi diverto a notarne le implicazioni per
esempio frasi tipo
insegnare non è riempire un secchio ma
accendere un fuoco
che questo però implica che loro però
gli alunni un po' di carta De carbonella
dei legnetti le cose combustibili le
devono portare perché se noi potremmo
avere anche il lanciafiamme ma succede
poco oppure frasi del tipo Ah avessi
avuto io un prof come Robin Williams il
professor Keating dell'attimo fuggente
con i suoi metodi innovativi e nessuno
riflette mai che per quei metodi
innovativi a fine film un alunno viene
cacciato il professor Keating viene
espulso e un'altra alunno si suicida
oppure frasi no che si dicono del tipo
nella scuola italiana si deve studiare
anche questa cosa Ah si dovrebbe
studiare anche questo argomento qui non
si può tralasciare questo autore Vabbè
bene Io sono contento quando anche
persone fuori dalla scuola suggeriscono
argomenti suggeriscono dei temi però
siccome poi gli orari sono sempre quelli
suggeriteci anche cosa togliere
perché lo dico perché anche perché poi è
stato calcolato che noi in richiami sul
comportamento
noi impieghiamo hanno fatto un calcolo e
una media 10 minuti all'ora un'ora al
giorno 38 giorni all'anno due mesi due
mesi a dirette zte
per cui quando avrò uno vede quelle
frasi Ah avessi avuto io un prof come
Roberto Benigni a spiegarmi la Divina
Commedia e nessuno pensa mai che Benigni
parla a della gente che sta zitta
Cito Cito Benini Non a caso Perché io ho
sempre sostenuto pensato in maniera
convinta che il docente deve essere
anche un attore Anzi sono più preciso Un
comico e questo io sono sono talmente
convinto di questa cosa che io da anni
ho provato a indagare le relazioni tra
questi due mondi per unire anche il
mondo della scuola al mondo del teatro
il mondo dell'Istruzione della
formazione al mondo della comicità è
proprio mentre costruivo provavo a
costruire questi Ponti mi sono chiesto
delle cose o meglio una grande domanda
si è sempre posta di fronte e cioè
perché nella scuola pubblica italiana si
ride così poco perché c'è così poca
ironia perché c'è così poca leggerezza
così poco umorismo questo Balsamo
salvifico che rende facile qualunque
lezione ci ci rende capaci di vedere con
visione laterale anche aspetti diversi
di ogni di ogni argomento e allora io ho
provato un po' a rispondermi le risposte
che mi sono dati sono state due mi sono
state due due risposte prima risposta se
come dice Gianni Rodari l'idea che
l'istruzione debba essere qualcosa di
tetro è veramente dura da scardinare
forse è perché i docenti italiani non
sono stati formati a questa competenza
c'è la capacità di usare l'umorismo in
classe questo Balsamo relazionale anche
l'umorismo per vedere aspetti diversi
degli argomenti trattati a scuola non
hanno quella che il professor Salvatore
Attardo chiama la competenza umoristica
un'altra grande studioso dell'umorismo
il professor Giovanni Antonio forabosco
dice che in realtà l'umorismo a scuola è
sempre esistito ma senza una piena
cittadinanza diciamo quasi una dimora di
fatto però purtroppo mai ufficialmente
riconosciuta ed è un peccato perché si
può ridere davvero di tutto quando io
ero studente No era bello perché quando
ridevo tra i banchi ridevo e il prof mi
fulminava con frasi tipo Ridi ridi bene
chi ride a giugno
che poi si può ridere di tutto che ne so
io sono stato per anni precario sono
stato così precario che il mio contratto
era scritto a matita
fate oppure
per esempio l'edilizia scolastica che è
messa veramente male nella mia scuola ci
piove dentro
pure quando fuori no
se messi così male che quando siamo
andati in gita alle rovine di Pompei la
Jasmine una mia alunna mi fa Prof ma
perché da noi a scuola i turisti non
vengono
e che in Italia Abbiamo due tipi di
scuole le scuole private e le altre le
scuole private di tutto nella nostra
scuola bagno docenti non ci sono i soldi
per comprare la carta igienica poi noi
Vabbè abbiamo risolto
i temi dell'esame del 94 eh
nessuno veniva a richiedere Insomma poi
veramente la data la data ci ha messo di
fronte ad un problema il fatto che i
docenti italiani sono stati veramente
gli ultimi a provare a stare dietro al
rinnovamento tecnologico poi ce
l'abbiamo fatta ma perché è stato
difficile perché i docenti italiani sono
appunto la classe di insegnanti la
classe docente in media più anziana al
mondo con insegnanti di latino
madrelingua
poi
maestre d'asilo di 68 anni lasciate sole
a inseguire 20 pischelli di tre quello
Dico Ministero almeno metti la legge che
l'età del docente non deve superare la
somma dell'età degli alunni
poi con la data veramente abbiamo
toccato con mano il Digital Devid No con
la Dad vi ricordate pochissimi Si
collegavano perché non tutti avevano i
dispositivi No ma altro che dispersione
scolastica era proprio Chi l'ha visto
c'era un assenteismo che avrebbe
scandalizzato alcuni euro parlamentari
poi la scusa era sempre quella cioè
prima a scuola arrivavano tardi perché
troppo traffico in quel momento in Dad
non si collegavano perché troppo
traffico
poi vabbè Vai a spiegargli che dad dad
ragazzi è un acronimo non è un
inglesismo vuol dire didattica a
distanza nonché i compiti te li deve
fare papà capito Patri io poi coi
compiti ero un po' molto comprensivo
Infatti avevo messo una regola ci si può
giustificare Però al massimo tre decessi
per ogni nonna
No no facciamo di più
Eh sì poi coi voti poi questi voti vuoi
che cambiano No prima dei numeri 6 7 8 9
poi giudizi notevole discreto poi sono
arrivate le lettere a pcp poi i giudizi
lunghi L'alunno a quando gli emoticon
per i voti
un'altra frase che gira spesso sui
social è se io non riesco a imparare
come tu insegni Allora Insegnami come io
imparo
che vabbè ma siete 35 in classe imparate
in 35 modi diversi e io sempre uno forse
due siamo in classe come fare beh questo
mi fa correre ad un altro problema mi
collego veramente al problema per cui
forse mancano leggerezza nelle nostre
scuole il fatto che abbiamo davvero
troppi casi particolari da gestire Cioè
è veramente veramente troppi troppi casi
diversi perché per esempio una classe da
22 alunni non è una classe pollaio Ma è
una classe in cui comunque non possiamo
veramente fare quello che le Indicazioni
nazionali ci dicono di dover fare Cioè
personalizzare la didattica la nuova
frontiera è quella della didattica delle
competenze cioè l'utilizzo sempre come
risorsa presente della alunno mettere in
pratica le competenze e Ma appunto le
mettono in pratica tutti in 35 modi
diversi è come si fa
per esempio Noi abbiamo tanti casi
particolari Noi abbiamo Zuretti Zuretti
un alunno un misto tra Franti e Hannibal
Lecter
e siccome con 35 alunni Cioè se gli
esami non finiscono mai con 35 alunni
pure gli scrutini cioè noiretti sto
zuletti sotto tre anni che lo
promuoviamo
perché si è fatto tardi
arriviamo lì la preside fa adesso
discutiamo di zuletti presi da
mezzanotte promosso cioè poi con la data
è arrivata una roba Insomma una legge
che diceva che non bisogna comunicare le
bocciature in maniera traumatica
sono stati lì con lo psicologo a pensare
un modo insomma va bene l'abbiamo
trovato Zuretti
sei fortunato
i libri di quest'anno tornano buoni
anche l'anno prossimo
è così
Anche perché le specificità
didattiche Appunto Si possono veramente
seguire con l'insegnante di sostegno Ma
io non li abbiamo Io c'ho tutte le case
particolari senza insegnanti di sostegno
cioè ipovedente l'iperattivo il
cardiopatico il dislessico Lo straniero
il dislessico straniero che quindi Parla
bene No perché
invece la mia scuola di frontiera il
primo giorno Ho letto il registro no ha
fatto l'appello aimer all'ambascia Vai
nakal bananez berrani Piero Beach
Channel One driker the Nilsson Hernandez
più che l'appello sembrava la formazione
dell'Inter no
il primo italiano sta Undicesimo
Esposito così mino tra l'altro Cioè
manco a dire che poi è lui il
cardiopatico grave e allora ridete ma è
talmente grave come cardiopatico che io
quando spiego storia mi prende male e io
le grandi tragedie della storia
gliele metto giù lisce
Ah perché li ha presi una volta è venuta
mi ha detto Scusi ma lei nell'attività
sulla seconda guerra mondiale ha
raccontato che ci sono stati 55 milioni
di morti eh Ma sei pazzo così Mina
momenti di prendere un infarto lei deve
edulcorare
dica che questi qua
si sono persi
Vabbè e Hiroshima hanno esagerato coi
petardi
la santa inquisizione dei cardinali che
si sono fatti prendere la mano dal
barbecue Insomma io penso ce l'ho tutti
c'ho allora che poi
birovic birovic un alunno rom che cambia
posto ogni giorno
bravissimo in geografia perché
li ha visti i posti in montagna
poi c'ho abdulla lanbagi che mi è
arrivato l'anno scorso in barcone a
Lampedusa e che quindi è Insomma è una
questione seria perché poi lui è
arrivato qui Insomma è night Non parlo
italiano Cioè parla poco male insomma
senza verbi senza congiuntivi se
perfettamente integrato diciamo Insomma
vedi vedi con tutti questi casi potete
capire che veramente il grande salto e
quando devi provare a prendere i grandi
classici nostri classici della
letteratura italiana perché lettere
quelle insegno io devi provare in
qualche modo a fare la versione per loro
I Promessi Sposi per esempio la
maggioranza sono che ne so questo Sono
musulmani arabi e allora ti inventino
loro una versione per loro che è più o
meno
Quel ramo dell'Oasi di Damasco che volge
verso la Mecca tra due fila non
interrotte di Palme in quasi a
restringersi in una striscia chiamata
Gaza Però di questo strati ci vuole
tornava la sua moschea ogni mamma
leggiando alcune Sure del Corano quando
a un certo punto tu e predoni sui loro
cammelli si
ardash buonino buoni c'è anche la
versione indiana cosa faccio dopo
indiana no E adesso vado a lezione
indiana Vabbè Quel ramo del fiume Gange
che volge verso Calcutta tra le fila non
interrotte di vacche sagre mio padre
restringersi in un tempio yoga chiamato
Usai Baba ehm problema di queste strati
ci vuole tornavo al suo Ashram un
sacerdote bramino eh stia provando a
sturarsi tutti i chakra eh a un certo
punto incontra i due Marò i due
[Applauso]
non involtino primavera quando Nell'anno
del dragone un monaco buddista dopo aver
fritto Un po' di tutto a un bivio
incontra Bruce Lee e Jackie Chan che
dicono ha fatto l'Inter a coronavirus
[Applauso]
Senti per quasi restringersi in una
tortilla a forma di maiale quando c'è
gente Garcia travestito da sacerdote
azteco dopo la siesta un bivio oltre il
muro oltre il confine chi ti incontra
Donald Trump che era uno ma
anche la versione rom per birovic con
don Rodrigo che incendi alla roulotte di
Renzi e Lucia Diciamo che la versione
per leghisti con per il padre di
Gervasoni Quel ramo del film Pokémon
oggi verso Pontida andate via non
interrotte di ruspe ci ho anche la
versione par condiciola Guarda pt la
versione del PD perché c'ha la la la la
Rebecca cioè papà assessore PD quello è
un Renzi e Lucia che si separano in due
correnti diverse io ancora di sposarsi
c'è anche la versione per dislessici
quel Lugo del record di moto che gomiti
No no
così è troppo
con tutte queste diverse
richieste specificità didattiche
veramente difficile seguire tutti se
siamo troppi E allora questo
aggiungeteci poi che magari tutte le
leggi no la legislazione sugli
innalzamento dell'obbligo scolastico
si crea si crea un fraintendimento per
cui si pensa che innalzato l'obbligo
scolastico si innalza anche l'obbligo di
studio
[Risate]
che vai allora Tutto questo perché lo
dico perché bisogna che davvero noi
possiamo avere più tempo per ogni alunno
perché il tempo è il grande nemico della
pedagogia dobbiamo provare veramente a
dedicare più tempo ad ognuno quindi
forse con meno alunni in classe e quindi
allora come fare così Veramente noi
avremo meno cose da fare saremo più
leggeri la leggerezza tornerebbe a
scuola Come fare per avere classi più
piccole metodo numero uno se c'è qualche
docente lo può fare all'open day no
sapete quando Si invitano i genitori
possibili i futuri genitori no della
scuola no avvenire in quella scuola fate
come meglio olio per te mi faccio
trovare con la patta aperta
Salve così si scrivono in meno No e
io sarei qui il prof di italiano Piacere
di conoscervi Ci piacerebbe molto che
scrivete vostro figlio qui Questa è la
più meglio scuola del quartiere i
professori più meglio formati sono qua
la droga che si spaccia in cortile pure
la prof di matematica Scusate era
d'accordo con noi con questo piano
perché guardava i docenti e poi guardava
no che faceva l'occhiolino poi
guardavano tutti i genitori e diceva che
i genitori in questo plesso ci sono ben
tre laboratori linguistici nell'altro ce
ne sono due in tutto fa
quando è passata la circolare col totale
io non c'ero Insomma metodo numero 2
forniteci di un'astronave in questo modo
Noi prendiamo la classe la mettiamo
sull'astronave saliamo anche noi
sull'astronave viaggiando alla velocità
della luce un'ora di lezione diventano
due e allora noi possiamo Sì dedicare
l'attenzione giusta a ogni alunno metodo
numero 3 chiedere magari i nostri
governanti di sfruttare L'unica cosa
positiva offerta veramente Dalla De
natalità il fatto di creare i classi più
piccole massimo 15 alunni la scuola
finlandese quello fa di buono non che
non danno i compiti o che stanno in
mezzo ai giardini no classica 15 e poi
assenza di scuole private sono le
pubbliche così Anche i ricchi devono
farsi un mazzo così per fare in modo che
la scuola per i loro figli sia non meno
che fantastica
ma
Chiudo dicendo E vabbè ma questa cosa
costa E certo ma se non spendiamo i
nostri soldi nell'educazione perché
attenzione questa cosa curare la scuola
non è che riguarda solo i docenti o se
abbiamo un figlio a scuola no può
riguardare noi quando in futuro
passeremo su un ponte che può essere
costruito da una futura ingegneria
oppure saremo dei Passeggeri su un volo
guidato da un futuro pilota saremo
operati da un futuro medico Oppure
potremmo eleggere un futuro politico
tutte queste persone questi bambini e
queste bambine sono adesso alunni nelle
nostre scuole
ed è per questo che dobbiamo avere a
cuore tutto ciò per far tornare l'ironia
la leggerezza e fare in modo che
l'istruzione ritorni ad essere un volo
leggero e divertente
[Applauso]